well thanks again and thanks for having
me this is um
you know this is really an honor i i uh
you know in my career
there are often times uh discussions uh
people from around the world people i've
worked with
uh kind of scratching their head
wondering how to you know and
and formal formal you know ambassadors
and and you know
economic development agencies asking how
do we recreate silicon valley
and and and well certainly not in in in
its entirety but certainly a major part
of that is stanford
and uh i think that's going to be hard
to replicate so i think they gotta
you know they'll they'll keep asking
that question it's an honor to be here
um i you know i love i love
uh telling this story uh to
to students people like you i certainly
hope to inspire you
i hope not to scare you um
but i i think i think uh you know maybe
i'll just tell the story from my
perspective
and i think you know one of the key
things i often tell people is
is whatever you read about company
formation and and the mythology of
companies
starting and whatever you hear about or
read about certainly read about in books
the real story is is a lot more nuanced
and it's also very much depending on
your perspective so
i'll tell you from my perspective uh
what the last uh five years have been
about
have been about and i certainly am very
interested in any questions you might
have
um uh when we're done i'll suggest
perhaps uh some
some pointers uh you know my my learning
uh where i stand today uh with
everything that's happened
and and you know maybe maybe to sum them
up
first is if you're gonna start a company
if you're gonna start a new endeavor
i would offer that it's good to you know
generally people say it's really good to
try something big and disruptive
um i think probably on paper and for a
lot of reasons that that makes a ton of
sense and you can you can go a lot of
different directions but i think
you know one reason to go do something
big and disruptive is because it's
incredibly difficult to do
and the odds of success are so low that
if you're going to go do it you might as
well
you might as well spend spend all that
time and energy and sacrifice doing
something that you think is really
important
and in hand with that i think is is it's
got to be something that you
really really care about internally and
i think it's
it's hard to even express maybe my
thoughts on this it's not it's not that
you
care about it it's that you can't stop
thinking about it it's that
when you wake up in the morning you you
see something that is a missed
opportunity or something
somebody else is missing or you you have
an attachment or a passion about
something
that is so great uh that you know
if if it makes sense to to kind of start
a start an endeavor start up a start up
a company to try to address it
um you care so much about it uh that you
just
can't get out of your head and you're
not gonna be satisfied until you've made
a go at it
because again that's gonna be important
too maybe another key learning
you'll have ups you'll have downs uh you
may win uh you may lose
uh if you want my my input you the
experience itself is worth it
uh you you you know that alone just it
it truly is one of those things where
the journey is what matters um
not necessarily the outcome um but you
will
you know it will it you will have your
your highs and your lows
uh and this is where i think that you've
got to
maybe balance and level and understand
on a variety of levels luck has a lot to
play with it
you know market externalities uh
externalities on the competitive
landscape
you know there is a lot that has to do
with whether or not you and this new
venture would succeed
and for two reasons i think it's
important one is a public service
announcement there's
you know there's plenty of people that
start companies and have great success
and then
proclaim to the world what a genius they
are and how they knew it all along and
you know i
i summarily reject that that mythology
that there's kind of
one creative force and one person that
makes it happen
um it takes a team uh it takes it takes
a team it takes a group of individuals
to do anything uh worthwhile
i also recommend that to people to make
sure to understand
i you know i again the downside is a
very real possibility
uh and you and you know i think you
should still if you're gonna try this
kind of thing you should steal yourself
for that outcome
and not personalize it you know do your
best if you've got a passion about
something
do your best to build something that
makes a difference but a lot can happen
and if you end up failing in the in the
in the process
you know that's how this works pick
yourself up
you know dust yourself off go find
another team to tackle another problem
and go do it
um and then i think you know speaking of
team you know that's maybe the other key
lesson that i've learned is is
you know the team you start with the
team that joins you
the team that invests in you um it is
you know my perspective my two cents on
it are
it is very much about the team that you
choose to go through this with
and should you at any point along the
way start you know experiencing success
in building and growing
um i think in retrospect i would say you
know
all of the energy and we've we've we'll
get a little bit into it we've put a lot
of energy
into our team and how the place works uh
and
even to the point where in the early
days i thought it might have been a
little overkill certainly since there
was a very high likelihood of success we
wouldn't be around anymore
in in when the money ran out but now
looking back i actually
think every ounce of energy we poured
into the way we wanted to work the way
we wanted our team to work
now is is now it's coming back it's
coming back and i'm not only glad we put
as much energy as we did i actually wish
we did more you can't
put enough energy into your team in the
way the way the place works
so those are those are the major
learnings i'll start from the beginning
um
you know the i was at a company i was a
ceo at a company called navigenex it was
one of the
kind of middle uh mid mid thousands
direct to consumer
genetics plays um you know a lot of good
ideas floating around then
we were basically the physician oriented
stodgier less fun version of 23 and me
and that's that's that was our plan we
were going to go take genetics to the
masses
really kind of employ health plans
doctors whatever
it didn't work for a lot of reasons it
didn't work um business model
uh timing you know uh you know not
don't need to go into it now but it
didn't work but what what i did get at
the time
uh you know from my experience in the
industry i was in the tools diagnostics
um you know technology industry leading
to that
you know knowing where you know kind of
the microarrays in use at the time that
dna microarrays kind of were the
beginning the harbinger of what was to
come
in genetic technologies at the time a
bunch of sequencing companies had been
developed developing next-generation
sequencing technologies that promised to
lower the cost of access to the human
genome
and while the business that we were
trying to build what you know just it
just wasn't
working what i did see bouncing around
from
medical geneticist offices to genetics
clinics to doctor's offices talking with
genetic counselors
what i did see um was the beginning of
what we
what we started and what i saw was you
know in fact
there are a lot of genetic disorders
there are a lot of genetic diseases and
there are a lot of people impacted by
them and what struck me most is
none of the clients that i was talking
to were happy about the way it worked
genetic counselors medical geneticists
you know cardiogenesis cancer geneticist
you know
even you know clinicians that were
vaguely aware of how how genetic testing
worked
nobody was happy um you know things were
very expensive
very very long lead times you know if
you ordered a test it could take you
know up to half a year to get an answer
um you know just really kind of
almost primitive given where the
technology was at the time it was going
but even more even more importantly this
is where you know kind of
you know it really came clear to me a
couple of uh family
events not my not my personal close
family but you know kind of you know
related related family and friends and
their families
you know a couple events in their lives
that had big impact on that family
devastating impact on those families and
then in these clinics what i would see
are not the same families but equivalent
families sitting there with their kids
in these clinics um
and after kind of knowing the the
situation with the genetic counselors
certainly talking with some of these
families along the way
understanding just getting a good feel
for the absolute despair
that they were going through um
seeing you know in these clinics these
kids i mean you know i actually at the
time
when we started the company i just
become a relatively new parent
um and you know you can i don't know if
any of you hopefully not
probably not a lot of your parents wait
on that one
that's my other piece of advice life
advice wait to have kids
um but you know you think you know most
parents most new parents kind of think
they have it tough they don't get to
sleep they have troubles
seeing these parents with these kids
that were not developing
that were not growing that were having
serious serious problems
really put it in perspective for me
these people had
problems i will never have problems most
likely
that these people have and i think as i
as i kind of went through that
experience
that's what then stuck in my head as
this is ridiculous this is ridiculous
that given where the technology is today
these people wait so long for the
testing they can't even get access to
testing the clinicians don't even tell
them about the testing because it costs
twenty thousand dollars to get it
and very likely won't give them an
answer anyway
that's when it kind of all started
coming together so i kind of at that
point put it together
i knew where the next generation
sequencing technology was going
effectively
the cost per base of the human genome
was dropping off faster than moore's law
which i think you know
i mean we all know what moore's law did
for you know computing networking and
and
everything that has followed and it was
pretty clear about five years ago this
is
this is what's going to happen in
medicine uh this is what's going to
happen in genetics
and you know i'm gonna go we're gonna go
figure out
how to how to make this work so we
decided uh it was myself
a couple other people that were working
with me at the time we
kind of popped out decided to go start a
company and
the idea was hey let's let's build a
company
that will consolidate the three to four
thousand some odd genetic disorders
the tests for these three three thousand
four thousand different genetic tests
consolidated into one highly efficient
industrialized
platform production line to consolidate
the entire genetic testing industry
drive the price of the floor and make it
available to everybody
and that's what we started with and
while there was no way at that time
i could really know exactly where it was
going i certainly couldn't know that
i would be standing here today telling
you about it that's essentially what
we are doing so in vitae in vitae now
we are you know we're basically
hellbent for leather on bringing you
know bringing genetic testing into
mainstream medical care
for literally billions of people on the
planet you know anybody in the
development healthcare system
can benefit from this i mentioned the
three to four thousand genetic disorders
you know that i kind of became familiar
with you know many years ago
in fact it affects possibly up to ten
percent of any given population in ten
up to ten percent of the population has
an inheritor genetic disorder
it's just that they're so fragmented
three to four thousand of them are
spread
that any one of them seems small enough
the biggest one the biggest market in
solid america by far is that breast
cancer testing myriad does it cetera but
there's a long tale of these genetic
disorders
and so that's that's what we set out to
do and indeed
thankfully that's what that's what we're
still doing we went out
we went out to raise money this was uh
this was end of 2009
not the best year to go out and raise
raise venture capital and in fact it
turns out
uh of the you know we pitched to more
than 110 uh places firms uh
funds what have you uh it turns out half
of them didn't have any money
so you know knowing knowing you know
seeing where the those firms went now
half of them just didn't have any money
the the crash had happened things were
rearranging capital was
getting reallocated um so it was a long
haul we pitched more than 110
really for about a year um
it was a tough it was a fairly tough
time actually that that was kind of the
first set
about six maybe six to nine months into
it was the first time i really
faced uh the potential for failure
like squarely in the face um you know
the team the team that we were working
with or there were four of
us uh we were kind of self-funding it we
had some space we got going
uh we actually we started originally in
the tres agaves tequila tasting room
up there in uh in in san francisco uh
we're there for about a month and a half
one of the one of the co-founders
that knew the owner so we holed up there
then we moved to the qb3 space over in
mission bay
uh so we had some space we got some of
the equipment up and running and we were
getting going
confident that we were going to raise
money but then after six to nine months
you know just no after no after no after
no part of the team started shaking
loose a little bit you know
they needed to go get a job their their
spouses were like hey how long are you
going to pursue this crazy dream
um that summer right before you know we
got a couple of these firms interested
was definitely the first time
certainly in my career ever uh that i
really stared failure in the face um you
know i'm a
i'm a fairly confident individual no
one's ever accused me
of a lack thereof but boy that
experience there that was trying and and
that's by the way
that's why i think you should do it i i
think you should
i think you should do it just for that
experience
um it's been invaluable to me just
facing that failure in the face
you pulling these three people along uh
invaluable invaluable and really
actually
frankly prepares you for the next phases
of company formation um
uh so we we we pitched 110 115
no's got a couple interested and finally
uh one of the firms that we had been
talking to
um we got the a round and got going
i think uh you know at the time the idea
seemed
stupid uh the pitch the pitch was kind
of
hey this technology curve is happening
there's this big unmet
need we're going to build this engine
the sequencing engine that's going to be
able to deliver clinical reports
uh better faster cheaper than anybody
consolidate the industry we're going to
go for 50
gross margins it's going to be an
execution play no intellectual property
bearer to entry
uh at the time the fda was rattling
sabers about sequencing in ldts at the
time the gene patents were fully in
effect and there was a patent thicket
you know kind of hovering over every one
of these ideas
the idea of building a biotech company
with with a long-term aspiration of
getting to 50
gross margins was completely foreign to
any investor in the space
and then of course you know when you're
raising money as i hope a lot of you
will try to go do you know
the thing you get asked all the time is
what's your what's your differential
advantage and
if the answer is because we know what
we're doing and we're going to work
harder than anybody else is not a
compelling
argument to somebody who's got a very
very high cost of capital
so you know it is understandable it took
a while um
but we did eventually get some investors
that i think frankly i think they were
the end of their fun and they just took
a flyer on the idea they said these guys
seem crazy enough we'll just
give it to him and see what happens so
we got going
we started uh started hiring the team
started getting going um and
you know one of the one of the very
early things uh that that
i mean obviously has led to a lot of the
success we've had
constantly seeking out uh people that
had been a bit been through before
people have done it before in the
fundraising process i mean you know i
look i've i was ceo of a company i've
run large business units at tech global
business units at technology companies
it still was an incredible help to run
the pitch
by four or five people that i knew that
had raised money before who had been vcs
before
started companies before you know a
month month and a half of that
preparation
was invaluable uh you know and i that's
one thing i would say right from the
get-go get people who have done this
before
run it by them run it by and run about
drill it with them
really test your assumptions uh then
when you know once we got funded
it was time to start filling out the
board and i started reaching out to
people i knew people in the space
and you know i was really interested in
getting randy scott randy scott had
founded insight
took them public randy scott had founded
genomic health took them public
you know very very early player big
player in personalized medicine and i
just kept calling him and calling him
and calling and trying everybody i knew
that knew him
uh i finally got on his calendar shortly
after we raised the first round went to
talking about joining the board
uh and and you know here was a person
who after really spending a year and a
half
talking to just about everybody in the
industry experts on the medical
technology
investor side alike basically saying it
was a horrible idea
you know i spent you know within 30
seconds of tying with randy
i can see his facial express like he's
clear he gets it and then he starts
talking about oh and then this and then
this and it was
it was clear um that i had found i had
found my uh my board members so we we
kind of got going there um got randy on
the board i had another
board member come in kind of a
experienced hand in the diagnostic space
and i think this is where you know not
just in the company formation but
early days along the way having
experienced people people have done it
before
people that challenge you on what you're
doing how you're doing it
is invaluable and this is where i can't
say enough
where i think there's that you know
again i hear the mythology
myth around companies um and again
my perspective is it's quite different
you have an idea of what you want to do
you are the driver at the time i was the
driving force of getting this to happen
but there is no way that we would have
made it happen without these
these individuals banging on the idea
testing the idea
testing assumptions bringing in their
network to test the assumptions further
do channel checks build models etc
invaluable invaluable some of the things
we definitely fought on
the price point for example was one of
them one of the early kind of founding
concepts was we are going to make this
as low price as possible and we know one
day in the future
we'll catch up on the cogs and you know
again anybody with any experience in the
diagnostic industry will tell you it is
really hard to run
a low margin business and diagnostics um
and we battle on that we battle that and
that was one thing where i said
you know where i think you know i did we
did stick to the founding purpose of the
company
um and even though there was a lot of
early
not fighting but you know debate about
it
one thing that kind of strikes me which
is which is another really important
thing is
these individuals shared the same
passion that
i and the team did these individuals had
the same values
as i and the team did you know
ultimately when it came down to
what is our real model what are the
actual moves we're going to make by way
of pricing or offering
it is it is it is absolutely essential
that all of the people involved share
the values share the core mission so
that that kind of goes back to you know
if i
can impart one thing on you really
having that core
mission the core you know what it is you
are trying to accomplish in view
and having everybody on the same page on
that makes you know makes these things
possible
that is the only way we got past those
early days kind of you know
testing things out technology risk
market risks
trying to get clients all the debates
about pricing and offering
the fact that these individuals had so
much experience and could really push us
as well as the fact that they shared the
vision really kind of exit us in what i
think kind of the early
phases of the company the first two
years or so first you know two rounds of
financing
um essential essential for it
now the thing is so while when we
started um
you know i think a lot of people thought
it wasn't such a great great idea
things started moving pretty quickly um
so when you went to the medical
conferences and the clinical conferences
instead of every every talk being about
how
next generation sequencing you know was
10 years away 15 years away
you know kind of the the typical
technology cycles in our space
would seem about two years into it it
would seem that they were actually
moving a lot faster um acceptance by the
clinical community
uh the prices actually you know many
many of the investors we talked to
just looked at our price model and said
you are crazy price costs are not going
to come down that fast
uh and indeed actually they were coming
down faster so people were just shocked
even
even i who you know had been in the
industry a while um and
kind of i think of myself as perhaps an
overly optimistic technology zealot
even i was shocked how fast these things
were coming down
and so things really started to move in
the industry and really kind of turned
our
you know out of left field crazy
moonshot of an idea into something that
all of a sudden everybody started
thinking actually that's not such a bad
idea
and then you've got all of the industry
incumbents thinking that way and you've
got all of the
120 investors that you talked to two and
a half years ago
thinking oh yeah that's a great idea
let's do it and so people start
surrounding around the space
and this was a period of time where you
know we had to start making some
decisions
and they were really really tough
decisions and i think it's
you know the way i think about it or the
way i would i would tell you from my
perspective is
you know this is this is kind of the the
classic um
you know big piece small pie small small
small piece big pie
kind of thing that a lot of you know
most entrepreneurs face at some point in
time in financing
it's also one of of control right so you
know
you know i'm running this shop i've hand
built hand selected the team
we are making progress and then at some
point right again the market starts
shifting
everything moves we knock off the
technology risk we prove it can be done
externalities seem to be going in our
favor fda
basically goes away for a while at the
change of the administration's
the gene patent thicket that was pretty
much assumed to be
something that would block our kind of
model forever showed signs of cracking
the the first case
started popping up through the federal
court through the district courts
that was challenging patents you know
subject matter uh patentability for for
gene sequences itself
and in that period of time a lot of
people started getting
interesting interested in the space a
lot of people started getting interested
in us
it became clear to us it was turning
into an execution play and
at that point then you've got these you
know industry veterans around the table
you're looking at in our kind of
business model what matters
when it starts turning into an execution
play essentially it turns into a foot
race
and you start asking you start coming to
the realization that you need a lot more
capital than you thought you did
if you know again if you really want to
go for what it is we wanted to do if we
really wanted to go after
all of the families that are currently
not able to get this information for
their for their kids for themselves
we were gonna have to spend a lot more
money and so that started going into
decision making mode where
there were a couple companies that we
had been kind of partnering with that
then all of a sudden
threw up threw over acquisition offers
um
there you know in that you're kind of
you're kind of making the decision well
gosh we could probably raise you know
another maybe another 10 million round
on our own
but you know really if we want this to
happen we want to have it at scale maybe
we should tuck into a larger company
and and just and just see this through
um
that's trying as in you know you've
spent the last you've basically
sacrificed the last two and a half years
of your life getting to that point and
now
the best options in front of you seem to
be the ones that remove your control
you know it's not what you it's not why
you started the company but but again
if if you know for us it was very much
one of like look
it what matters most is that what we're
doing sees the light of day and has
impact in the market
and so we seriously entertained a lot of
that um
or for a while we entertained those
those um those bids
um did the diligence had the
conversations
uh soul-searching times to be sure and
then then what happened then
randy who was on our board um again i
think got
so excited about it all he kind of said
okay we yes we could raise a small round
and kind of go to loan but
you're just not going to make it it's
just it's just you know he
he amongst most knows you need a lot of
capital to to make changes in in these
spaces
um the acquisition offers well yes
that's probably
barring our internal round the best way
is to to go ahead and be acquired um
make it happen but even then then you
run the risk that you just get is
subsumed by a big company and everything
that you've tried to build doesn't
actually
get out there and so he suggested hey
how about this instead i'll lead i'll
lead the c round
uh i'll bring in a bunch of investors
and we'll we'll fund this thing and
we'll do it right we'll go
we'll go for the long shot we'll go for
the big win we'll go all the way um
and you know this is going to take 300
million dollars and so let's do that and
you know
turns out that that that's that's the
way we went that was certainly the right
call
um for his pains of course he was going
to be ceo
in instead of me and and that's where
that you can it all came in it's like
okay you know
which door do you go through what are
your personal incentives
it all kind of came back to again if you
wanted to get if i wanted to get this
done
this team who would join me want to get
this done this was this was definitely
the best way to do it
it meant taking a smaller piece of a
bigger pie it meant giving up control
the company it meant a lot of things
that you
you know at the time were tough um but
honestly i mean looking back
there was no other way to do this there
was no other way to do this
that was the right way to go and i think
that's where
you know i want to on that point in
particular i
today i talk to a lot of entrepreneurs
that are in that tweener phase of the
company they got some funding they're
getting going
and they're making these decisions and
they know they need the money but that
means losing control and they know they
need a partner or
but it means partnering you know i would
say
that is a key point in the if you're
going to start a company that is going
to be a key
challenge um as you start to succeed
uh again if you want my advice the best
thing to do
is do what's right for the mission
remove yourself from the equation
that's the best way to succeed i've seen
people get all tied up in what their
percent ownership it is it's you know my
vision my company
we're going to do it my way that's
that's
that's a tough that's a tough that's a
tough path to continue
for everything that we read about in the
public media how that's that's the you
know obviously the one or two of those
the unicorns that make it out and that's
the case that's all we ever read about
but i can assure you the thousands of
other companies
you know most of which die on the vine
that is that is not the way it works
um you've got to be willing to to
sacrifice your own
personal ambitions and desires for the
mission at hand
um which so so then we so at that point
in time we raised
we raised a you know a good size c round
certainly more than we'd
ever raised in a and b um
things started working uh we started
adding more teammates and this is where
again this is where the team comes into
play you know
you know you you you want to bring in
people
that then can keep moving the company
through the next phases right and
they're going to be different people
than the people you started the company
with they're going to have different
skill sets
they're going to come from different
backgrounds and in a tight
knit kind of you know no safety net
environment like a startup company
they're going to seem like they're from
a different planet to to you and much of
your team
but it's essential it's essential that
as the company scales and grows you add
these people and that's what we did we
started
getting ready to you know we had proven
commercial success again the technology
risk was peeled off a while back we
started proving commercial success
and now it was time to start building an
organization that could really go out
and go after it so there was a period of
rapid company building
a lot of different skill sets showing up
the other thing that happened
uh happens you know starts happening at
that time so now we now we have access
to more and more capital more more
capital is coming in
which then starts opening up the
decision set so kind of up until then
you know every month was basically a
race against dying as a company you know
we
we have nine more months of cash we need
to prove this this and this we have six
more months of cash this and we have
three more months of cash
we have no more cash our bridge loan
takes us one more you know four more
weeks six more weeks eight more weeks
then all of a sudden you've got more
money than you ever thought you would
have
you've got a bigger team around you and
now the questions get a lot harder in
terms of okay
now how do you create value for the next
round of investment or do we need to get
going thinking about going public
can we get to break even before then you
know and in that period of time with
many more voices around the table
it can get a bit crazy and indeed in our
you know the
the that middle kind of maybe this is
about two years ago in our company's
history
there were a lot of ideas about a lot of
different directions to go um
you know should we go this way more
direct to consumers should we go
you know absolutely hardcore traditional
clinical should we go somewhere in
between should we just
skip the us and it's crazy third-party
reimbursement system and go you know go
go outside of the country let's go let's
go to latin america let's go somewhere
where there's actually a market
for this information instead of this
bizarre you know like i call it the
the regular insurer you know the regular
ensure industrial complex that kind of
it does it it distorts markets in in
this country uh for the diet for
diagnostics and these technologies uh
it you know we can talk about later if
you have questions but you know
maybe we should do that instead um and
those you know those again you know
those are tough times now you're burning
you now you're burning on a monthly
basis
what you used to spend a year uh you've
got a lot more people coming in the
culture that you're trying to build
from day one gets challenged
consistently uh and you know
there was a period starting at about
this time this stat has continued with
us even today
at our company in avitay today more than
half the company has shown up
in the last six months right so of a
company we've been around for five years
and more than half of our head count
is here six months ago and that started
you know about in this period of time
about two two and a half years ago
and what we're trying to do you know
we're trying to build a different
culture i'll talk a little bit more
about it um
we're trying to build a different place
a different way of working and of course
when you're growing that fast with all
these new ideas and all these new people
coming in
that comes under serious serious
pressure
um and that so all that's coming
together at that time
and again to get through that time i
just keep as
i think back on it it keeps coming back
to the people around you you know you
have
excellent smart passionate people around
you you have
very experienced hands around the table
both both working with you on the
management front and on the investor
front you know so we started bringing in
these
blue chip investors that have been in
the space for a while that had seen a
lot
that were long-term investors that
really got us through that time
um and got us to the point where then it
was time to
think about you know we had now achieved
enough commercial success where
and by the way the markets were hot
enough i mean i think in a down market
would be tough but
you know we could actually see hey it we
can start raising more and more money we
could even think about getting the
public markets to really
continue to accelerate continue to lower
the prices continue to make this happen
um and you know in the back and forth of
all this that's what we decided to do we
started gearing up to do it
right before that you know kind of at
the end of that period
we went out we went out to raise you
know kind of our last
private round or the way it works today
there's this kind of since the jobs act
there's a lot more action from
what traditionally have been called
mezzanine investors
or early ipo investors they also now are
investing in kind of
basically the last private round of
public companies so we begin talking to
those firms
which which i would say you know that
really started
focusing our attention on what is our
story going to be you as we go out to
access the public markets
uh and again our team helped us our
the team we had added uh you know we
couldn't have done it without them no
way
the investors that we had added along
the way we could have made it happen
without them
uh you know interesting little story we
we actually went out did the
kind of the non-deal road show we were
out raising the private round
um you know with the bank we had the
bankers involved we had we actually had
at one point we were going out to raise
you know 50 million or so
had a lead we're about to close it uh
and then you know literally
on a friday afternoon the banker called
on on a call and said oh you know huh
sorry guys lead fell through you know
you know big big big mutual fund x
is starting to wonder what's going on
huge hedge fern why
wants to know where are we are we going
to close soon
um you know very quickly what looked
like a pretty good like let's raise 50
million it was all coming together
fell apart yeah in a matter of minutes
um
that was harrowing to to say the least
uh that's a period of you know you're
burning a ton you you know it's not like
back in the first
first early rounds when you're burning
you know a couple hundred k a month
um you know you you have a financing
fallout then
and maybe everybody sours on the story
and all of a sudden you're
like going back to the company firing a
hundred people
you know it's not good not good at all
but you know the team rallied again
we've got
we've got pros around the table um you
know the team rallied
and we you know we ended up actually
turning into a major major win
very quickly we found another lead which
is actually even better than the first
lead we had
and instead of raising a 50 round 50
million dollar round we ended up closing
120 million dollar
d round and and i think that's one of
those things kind of as i think about
that financing itself kind of is a lot
of the experience now that's
that's a financial effort but i think
same thing has happened on the
technology side as we've been working on
different ways to look at this sequence
information get it into the clinic
different ways to run the pipeline
a lot of the failures that we've had
very very quickly got turned into wins
that were
even bigger than than the failure we
experienced
and i think that's you know part of the
part of the programming that i would
suggest you're going to need to have
um you're going to face a lot of
adversity you're going to have a lot of
downs
with your ups and the you're you know
you and the team around you your natural
reaction needs to be
okay now what do we do how do we fix it
how do we get going how do we preserve
and again i keep coming back i keep
coming back to in my mind you know
every single one of those kind of
circumstances that we hit along the way
that is possible when everybody is on
the same page and everybody's passionate
about the mission
and everybody can suspend what it means
for them oh my god we just we
we're about to bail out of our d round
what's going to happen what's going to
happen to me what's going on what's
happening next
all these relationships are going to
fall apart instead everybody was
dead set focused on no no no this we
need to make happen
you know our clients are loving us the
patients are getting the results
like we are going to make this happen we
are going to make it happen we're going
to pull it out
uh and i think of you know the drought
financing falling through a bunch of
technology
follow-ups along the way that we had
every single one of those
when you started you know again it's
kind of back to when you're facing that
failure
uh and then the team rallies around it
and the team always rallies around it
for the right reasons not only do i i
suggest to you that is absolutely
critical in building a business
uh that hopefully again we i wouldn't
say we're a going concern yet but
look looking good so far you want to
build a business to that
to that point you're going to have to
have that and again it comes back to
kind of like
this is why i'm encouraging you to do it
those experiences
pulling through with a team for
something that is absolutely important
that the world needs even if you don't
succeed even if it does end up in
failure
that alone uh is worth it from my
perspective
and i can look i can honestly look back
and i think i think i can be honest with
myself even in the darkest times along
the way
the last five years every time we were
in a downtime i still
you know could come into work and remind
myself i would do this again
if if we don't close the bridge around
if we don't close the
c round if you know what just what i
just got
what just came out of the lab yesterday
if that if that ends up taking us
i would do it again every single one of
those times i i could always
i you know i think i mean it's hard when
you're there but i i think honestly
looking into myself i kept coming back
with i would still do it again
even if we fail crash and burn the next
week i would do it again
and i can tell you now even if along the
way you know it's easy to say now we've
gone public and
you know we're kind of making a go at it
um
but i can i can honestly say i would do
it again even if every time along the
way there was a chance for failure even
if it happened
i would totally do it again uh let's see
so so kind of so
so then uh so along the way we're having
commercial success we this was really
kind of
we had only been commercial for about
nine months almost a year at that time
uh we brought in chief commercial
officer really built the team up
but still a really small effort but we
were making great traction
um so we decided after the d round to
immediately
go and load up again and and access the
public markets and this i think
you know kind of all along the way i had
been receiving
from the very very beginning with no
money uh and no space all the way
up until that point in time i'd received
plenty of advice from a lot of people
about fundraising
and what i what i what i would offer to
you is the following i think kind of
there are two flavors of advice for
entrepreneurs on fundraising and one i
i think if i may vastly over-generalize
one comes from fairly wealthy people
that don't have to work
and think very deep thoughts about the
optimal way to raise money and build
companies
and the other comes from people that
aren't independently wealthy and have to
use other people's money and
just want to get something done and i
would say that the levels of advice go
something like you know this on this
side is kind of like the you know big
piece small pie is better you want to
optimize
every stage of value creation it only
takes so much solution along the way and
you know if you have cash make sure to
increase the value before you raise more
cash
and on the other side is is the simple
advice of take as much money as you can
when you can because you never know
what's going to happen tomorrow and i
i just got to tell you again one man's
perspective
that is the voice to listen to um and
even right after the d-run we had just
raised 120 million dollars
and the very next question was hey i
think we can get to the public markets
let's do it let's do it right now while
we can
because this is going to take a lot of
money and if we want to ensure success
that's what we're going to do
and so we did so we got we got gearing
up we got geared up
we went into in our in our industry
there's a big conference at the
beginning of the year the jp morgan
healthcare biotech healthcare conference
kind of went into that
having just announced okay we're going
to go do it
kicked off the road shows and then you
know um the great thing about the road
shows that we had just raised 120
million so we've been out talking all
these firms and a lot of them had just
come in and then we we got some more
interested
close the round uh uh close the ipo and
uh you know mid february
and took the company public came back to
the
company had a big party um and i'll
admit it was entirely surreal the whole
thing
uh you know on the one hand it's been
the longest five years of my life
um i think i've aged 20 in those five
years
on the other hand it just it just seems
like yesterday we were like literally in
that
trace against tequila tasting room kind
of like oh you know this could possibly
work maybe not you know how long you
have i don't know how long do you have
well let's
let's keep trying let's see if we can go
um it really has been surreal and and
and again i think reflecting on it well
and the first thing i would tell you too
is
is right now it's actually the way we
viewed it's kind of just the beginning
you know we
we we're making a we're making a great
ramp commercially
our value proposition is really selling
again it's kind of like hey you're
you're currently ordering and paying for
these genetic tests that are very
expensive and slow why not
come to us and have them be very very
fast and better and much much cheaper
you know it's an easy sell mostly
but it's really early days it's a big
market it's a complex market like i
mentioned the payer system's
difficult um there's a lot of challenges
ahead of us but you know it would seem
certainly from my part i think from my
perspective
uh where we are now is a maybe a not not
i wouldn't i wouldn't label it success
but it's kind of like you know for me
it's
all of the people that came and joined
all of the people that took
massive career risk on what we were
trying to do
you know minimally it looks good on
their resume now hey that company went
public i think yeah that's great
um you know minimally it is some kind of
like hey okay
this is working well enough where
there's enough people interested that
are willing to invest in the idea
and what i think is most interesting is
um
in these you know big funds these big
hedge funds these investors
what was really satisfying to me and
this again comes back to this this
concept that i'd
love for you to take away about the
mission um
the best thing was there's one woman
that runs this massive massive fun
very big important fun in boston and you
know to come in and be prepared for the
pitch and the questions and everything
and basically to have her kind of go
you guys have made my day i have been
looking for something in health care
like this
for years and i don't know why anybody
gets it if the technology is falling
prices are falling off the map why isn't
the care getting cheaper why isn't it
getting better why aren't patients
getting this
and it's kind of like you know to have
someone
like that in your corner which by the
way a lot of our investors
um are exactly the same way you know it
again it makes it all makes it all worth
it it makes it all
better and you know i think we're
genuinely at the point now where
even if we do fail um you know
prices in the industry have come down
since we came on the scene
turnaround times have come down since we
came on the scene there is no question
anymore whether or not people will do
genetic panels or
gene tests or whatever no that question
is now settled
it is now a race people anybody who
needs
tests will get one much much faster
uh you know and and i think not just
because of us
again there are a lot of industry
participants that are that are taking
part in this
but in a large part because we stuck it
out there and said this is where the
future is going to be
these things are going to be cheap and
available the margins are going to be
low and it's going to be a real
consumer market for this kind of thing
you know in a sense we have succeeded
no matter what happens at this point uh
and of course now
now that now the game is to make it
successful going forward so the the
maybe one last thing and then and then
we can go to questions i think the
the the point you know that i mentioned
is obviously i've been kind of pointing
out this this
this mission that the the burning desire
to do something has got to be front and
center
again for all the sacrifices you're
going to make to make it happen
and for all the chances of failure
you've got you've got to you've got to
have have it mean something and then
even in the success i can assure you the
success has nothing to do with
with with money or or you know going
public or anything the success is
is like i mentioned the people you're
interacting with saying this is awesome
this is an idea thank you for make it
happening we
um we now are kind of doing some work
with some advocacy groups and uh you
know we just recently had
um a uh you know one of these advocacy
group heads
uh her family has been affected and you
know to sit down and have her just kind
of
pour out her heart say you know i can't
believe you know this and this and this
and we need this and we need this and
it's just
it's a crime that this doesn't happen
and just to say we got it
we're doing it yes next year yes the
price you know
that is that is where the success really
feels like success none of the other
stuff
feels any different than when when i was
at my old job or when you know when we
were starting or when it was clear it
was possible we were going to fail
it's what you're doing that matters the
most um
the team that you build is what matters
the most and then i i mentioned that we
you know we that i felt it was really
important to pay attention to how you're
building the team and how you're running
it
so this is kind of this is kind of well
yeah i think it's interesting so we
we started the company um you know and
again i was a bunch of technology
people and we were really really excited
and excitable and going to change the
world
the other thing is is it kind of across
my mind um
you know we had all worked at many
places i had run fairly large units at
companies before
and it it kind of you kind of came hey
while we're out trying to do this
why don't we also try to create a
company that we actually like working at
you know
why don't we try to build a company
where
you know people enjoy coming to work
every day and and build a company where
maybe if we do possibly one day have
success and grow to be a ten thousand
person company
it actually is not your typical big
slow company um let's try to do that
and it was kind of a personal desire
that a lot of the all of the co-founders
shared
um to do that uh it was it was also
it was also a rational desire i think
you know kind of as i said
as i sat back at the time as i certainly
as i think today
you know an observation about the world
um
kind of lately technology cycles are
getting really really really
fast uh workforces are getting very very
distributed
um competition is popping up i mean you
know yes i think it's going to be hard
to recreate silicon valley
but boy there is a lot of global talent
pouring into
basically think of it as you know
entrepreneurial capacity
on just about any industry you can think
of and i can see it happening and so
kind of
one of the other ideas is not only like
why not build a place that's really
great to work at that we would
like to work at that you know people
don't run around basically
afraid of their bosses all the time why
don't we build a company that can
actually innovate at scale because i
actually think this is going to be
important
if we're going to have to stay on these
technology cycles if we're going to have
to stay
cut you know bleeding edge and access
global talent you know it's going to
have to work
differently than most companies work
today so we tried some things early on
we
we actually we didn't have an org chart
until 120 people
we didn't have any titles at all we
still don't have titles we now have sec
mandated titles but internally
you know we don't have titles that
convey rank or
entitlement or whatever they're very
functional practical titles
we built a uh the one of the first
things that i did
when we got the a round no this was
maybe when randy joined the board when
we built the board we built this little
survey system where the team would
basically do 360 reviews of each other
and especially me
and then that would get published to the
board and kind of you know the team
could basically either
with their name attached or anonymously
you rate me and how we were doing and
where we were going wasn't working
and that system has actually evolved and
over time and now we actually have it in
full play
our we don't have peer reviews at the
end of the year
you know our manager anybody who's a
manager we really want them just
focusing on execution and mentoring and
getting things done
and we have a separate group which is
our talent ops group and we have this
system that we've built
uh that is essentially like a
statistical
interpersonal you know kind of basically
a performance evaluation survey that's
completely 360.
um we gather many many many many
data points throughout the year and are
especially interested in how
i'm doing how randy's doing how the
leads are doing and so it's completely
upside down of kind of how most most
companies kind of do
personnel reviews who's doing what who
gets paid what you know who who gets
opportunities who doesn't
um you know we've we've uh we've
implemented a lot of unusual
features into into the way we operate to
preserve
some of that early early kind of nimble
you know nimble
the ability to be nimble the ability to
challenge the ability to chase ideas
and i think you know like i said we
spent a lot of time on it in the early
days and i felt at the time this was
probably too much
and now though that we're you know
getting the 250 people
with half the company you know hasn't
been here more than six months
i am really really glad we spent as much
time doing that because i've actually
really been delighted to see some of the
core cultural elements that that
certainly
i like about our company and we think
are going to be important for the
company
have not only survived they're starting
to bake in and people are really
starting to grab onto them as one of the
major reasons they like to work there
work here and honestly if we hadn't paid
as much attention to it early
on it wouldn't have happened we would
have we would have faced what
i talked to many many entrepreneurs
about many many founders about is that
you know
the tragedy of seeing this great thing
and as you achieve success
it starts getting away from you which
again you know to an extent it will
and that's good but then seeing the
culture go and seeing the you know
bureaucracy set in and and the fire go
away
um you know for me i again i i would you
know as you're starting a company
i exhort you to pay a lot of attention
to the type of people you're bringing in
and how you intend
to operate uh and manage those people
over time
so that's kind of a view you know from
start to finish that's that's
my personal perspective of what has gone
on
at nbt the last five years um let's do a
few
uh q a yeah i mean like i said i'd love
to
love to grab questions from anybody
oftentimes your your questions are much
more interesting than what i have to say
so yeah did you in the last five years
did you have any
big pivots or was it just a linear
execution no we knew what we were doing
from day
one and never no um yes of course yes
and and i think this is this is
universal and anybody i've talked to
that have done this
you pivot at some point uh early on it
was very much in
large part because of capital
constraints uh it was going to be
kind of a b to b type play we were gonna
we were gonna
build the technology engine and then
basically offer it as a b2b play to
labcorp and quest and myriad and these
other players and enable them
to lower the prices and expand the menus
when randy started getting involved when
the market started
shifting our direction it became clear
this is happening
fast and it's going to be much more of a
foot race that's when we decided that's
when
one major pivot was okay we're going to
go all the way all the way to the
clinician all the way to the patient
build a brand in the space and build the
whole thing
soup to nuts which of course is going to
take 10 times more capital than
the b2b play but that was a major pivot
and that's also what
increased the complexity of company
increased the size of the company that
was a major pivot
um we in that period i mentioned about
two and a half years ago we were
seriously considering going full-blown
kind of
i wouldn't say non-medical but really
pushing the bounds of
of the the you know kind of
our position our relationship vis-a-vis
the current medical establishment a
cup two and a half years ago we were
really kind of debating which way to go
and we were
pretty close or i think seriously
entertaining
maybe we needed to go around it uh
started gearing up to do so
but then kind of quickly pivoted back
and said no let's stick to our guns the
only way this is going to be impactful
for those families and those kids in
those waiting rooms in any near
any time in the near future is to get
the medical community going on it
serve their needs as well as the
patient's needs um
and get going so so kind of i'd say
those are the two major
you know big kind of one certain pivot
and one that was an almost pivot
that we quickly pivoted back um
yeah absolutely yep
it sounds like one of the key factors of
success is
the equipment you have and the
determination so
my question is is that based on just
your natural innate ability or is it
do you have techniques to kind of keep
going after maybe
so many no's that you uh initially got
um yeah oh sorry i think the question
was kind of like sounds like it takes a
lot of grit and determination
are you just insane or was that some
kind of choice you made along the way is
that the basic
um i i
i think those who work with me probably
think it's a little of the former
um but i'm not sure i i think i think a
lot of things in life come down to
choice and will
so so you you know if you if you really
want to do it and you decide you're
going to do it then it's just a matter
of sheer will
um and yes yes to do it you're going to
be
your will will be tested uh actually the
whole fundraising process
someone mentioned it to me at the time
and now it makes total sense
it's a bizarre way that people go about
raising money
but someone once said actually it's a
pretty good test for the next
the years to come and and actually now
it totally makes sense to me
you know getting kicked in the teeth all
the time told me it's a bad idea getting
strung along by vcs that have no
interest in investing you at all
um that's actually a pretty good testing
ground you can you can do that for a
year or so you just might
be able to then build a company and grow
it
yeah in board and i learned i don't i
don't know
but i prefer to think of it as if if you
find something that you really care
about and you choose
to go try to address it try to make that
difference
you know yeah you've got to make some
choices you will have to make sacrifices
you know i'm also not a believer and you
can have it all you know you want to go
do something as you build a company
you better simplify your life because
you aren't going to have a whole lot of
time you better figure out what's
important
focus on that and then make it happen
and yeah you're going to have to work
through a lot
to see it through and face a lot of
self-doubt and face a lot of challenges
but again that's that's kind of the
awesome thing about it
that that's you know you don't often get
an opportunity to really do that
you